[MUSIC PLAYING]
-How do native peoples perform
and protect their sovereignty?
We heard the last
panel about how
they do so via legal
and judicial means
in courts, both
Supreme and small.
And we heard how complicated
that process was, and is,
about struggles
with federal courts,
about the tensions between
tribal, and federal courts,
and about the tensions
between being a tribal judge,
on the one hand, and being a
federal judge, on the other.
It is all too easy to presume
that Native politics means
Native defeat.
But the history and the present
reality of Native politics
shows us otherwise.
We heard just a
few evenings ago,
during Kristiana
Kahakauwila's talk,
that Native Hawaiians
may soon come
into repossession of important
indigenous water rights.
Those who have
visited Taos Pueblo,
will recognize that, in 1970,
Taos Pueblo successfully
culminated a long-term
lobbying campaign
with the return of its sacred
Blue Lake, land and waterscape,
in the Act of 1970.
And today I note that
our keynote address
is being given by Rob
Porter of the Seneca Nation.
And the Seneca Nation,
in 1842, successfully
reversed critical portions of
the fraudulent Buffalo Creek
Treaty of 1838, which created,
in that successful reversal,
the two-- the three,
excuse me, reservations
on which the Seneca Nation
lives, thrives, and prospers
today.
We're going to talk about those
more political, less judicial,
aspects of native politics
and empowerment today.
And we've got three amazing
panelists with whom to do so.
We're going to proceed
in alphabetical order,
Karen Diver, to my
left, currently serves
as the Special Assistant to the
President for Native American
Affairs at the
White House, having
been appointed to that
position by President Obama.
She previously served nine years
as chairwoman of the Fond du
Lac Band of Lake
Superior Chippewa,
where she oversaw a workforce
of over 2,000 employees
for the second largest
employer in northern Minnesota.
She is uniquely
positioned to speak
toward internal domestic
tribal governance,
as well as, national
politics in Indian Affairs.
John Dossett, to her left,
is the General Counsel
to the National Congress
of American Indians, NCAI.
And his work includes
legal, legislative,
and intergovernmental
issues relating
to the rights of
tribal governments.
He has served in his
position since 1997.
And finally, to his
left, Sylvia McAdam
is from the Treaty 6 lands,
and a direct descendant
of Treaty People.
She is nêhiyaw and Nakawe and
speaks fluently in nêhiyaw.
McAdam is best
known as a cofounder
of the global grassroots
movement called,
Idle No More, which seeks to
assert the inherent indigenous
rights to its sovereignty, and
re-institute traditional laws,
and nation-to-nation treaties by
protecting the lands and waters
from corporate destruction.
We're going to begin
with Karen Diver,
thanks for being with us.
[APPLAUSE]
-Good morning.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
--[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
I'm Karen Diver,
Chairwoman Emeritus of the
Fond du Lac of Lake Superior
Chippewa.
It is primarily
in that role today
that I'm sharing some remarks
with you, not necessarily
that of the White House,
although I hang around
there a little bit, as well.
So I usually tell people that
now that I'm a bit removed
from being a tribal
chairwoman, that I
have a little bit of
post-traumatic stress syndrome,
and I'm thinking there should
be some kind of support
group for former
elected tribal leaders.
You know, they say, all
politics is personal,
well it's way different
when it's your aunties,
and that they can walk
right into your door.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm also really delighted
to be back here in Cambridge.
My year at the
Harvard Kennedy School
is actually one of the
most fulfilling years
that I have ever had the
privilege to be a part of,
particularly because
of HUNAP and getting
to know such bright, committed,
young, Native individuals.
I came as a little bit and of an
older student, so I was auntie.
I was the one that
actually brought real food
to the potlucks.
[LAUGHTER]
Which made me a rare commodity.
There's people here
who ate that food.
[LAUGHTER]
Why did I come to
Kennedy School?
I came to the Kennedy
School because I
was interested in learning
more from the Harvard
Project on American Indian
Economic Development.
Really one of the
only institutions
of higher learning that looked
at what does best practices
look like in Indian
country, around governance
and economic development.
I had saw my tribal community
go from an institution that
was very small, less
than 80 employees,
had a hard time
sometimes making payroll,
and had to pick between
payroll and the light bill.
And overtime-- just
extraordinary poverty.
Was the product of many
of my family members,
kind of participating, and
having federal Indian policy
impact their lives.
My dad was a
boarding school kid,
so he was taken away from
his family at age six,
with his brother, and
didn't really see them again
until they were eight
years old, lost his fluency
in the language, but never
forgot who his people were,
and where he came from.
My family chose to go away
on the relocation program
because they knew they had
to feed their children,
and in my small town, you just
didn't hire Native people back
then for the full-time jobs, the
good living-wage jobs, always
day labor and on the edge.
So I had the benefit of
being able to grow up
in an urban area, but what
my parents did for me is,
they put all four
of their children
through 12 years
of private school.
They put their money
where their values
were, which was in education.
So as I grew, and wanted to
make a better bigger impact
in my career, I knew
I had to learn more,
and I came here to learn it.
I went back home, and
started working for my tribe.
I worked as the director
of special projects
doing lots of different things,
a lot of program development,
administrative work.
And when the job opened
up as the chairperson
I thought I would give it a try.
My motives were
probably a little bit
different than previous
tribal chair people, in that,
I was mostly
interested in building
the institution of
governance, and building
an active citizenry.
Much just to my dismay,
when you start doing that,
they often practice
it on you, first.
But that's OK, right?
That's the stuff that
thick skin is made of,
and it's for the greater good.
So, the lesson I wanted to
work with my community on,
is this balance of
internal, versus external.
Very much Indian politics
in the home rule community
is about, how is
what you're going
to do in your elected office,
how does that benefit me?
How does this increase
my housing options?
my employment options?
And where really siloed
in Indian country,
I mean, the government
did a real good job
in making reservations,
they're very close,
they're very cloistered,
they're gulags.
And they intended-- the
purpose and the intention
of isolation of Native
communities, it worked.
We have a tribal people
now whom by and large look
to their tribal governments
for 100% of their daily needs,
everything from
their employment,
to their energy assistance,
to their recreational
opportunities, to access to
their language and culture,
and on, and on, and on, and on.
But how does that actually
relate to a broader world
that we're a part of?
And is that strategy OK
for Natives long term?
Well, we saw it changing
when we became more
of an economic entity, right?
So tribes were able
to take advantage
of learning Federal Indian Law,
and learning more about how
our governance relates to
the larger federal picture,
and we found a niche in the
market that allowed tribes to,
under civil regulatory
jurisdiction,
undertake a form of economic
development called, gaming.
That brought us to the attention
of broader communities in a way
that we had pretty
much not had before.
It was really easy to ignore
Native communities when
we were poor and dependent,
just stay on your reservation,
and stay out of our way.
Well, it's a whole
different thing
if you fast forward through
becoming economic entities,
and starting to become the
largest employer in your area,
if not a large
swath of your state.
Now people are paying
attention in a different way.
To me that really
meant we needed
to do some intention-- turn
our attention internally,
to our systems,
that we grow them.
To be able to have the
capacity to take on this larger
role and broader communities.
But we also needed to
get a little better
about communicating
what it is we are,
why we do what we do, how does
that matter to our people,
internally, within our home rule
community, and our citizenry,
and how does that relate
to the rest of the world?
All of a sudden we're bumping
into these multijurisdictional
issues.
Whether it's growing
our police department,
and figuring out how to do
mutual-aid agreements so that
we can serve our joint
citizens just as well.
The panel previous
to me, actually,
was a good foundation for,
kind of the way I looked
at what tribal governance is.
And, you know, people confuse
race with political status.
And that was a
constant mantra that I
had to have over and
over again, whether it
was with townships, or cities,
or counties, or the state.
Of saying, my citizens
are still your citizens.
They have an absolute
right to service delivery,
and your attention, and
for you to understand
what their needs
are, and balance them
with the rest of
your constituency.
You do not get to abdicate your
responsibility to your citizens
just because they are tribal.
I will share that
with you, but I
will hold you accountable
for your service delivery.
You don't get to not
send your police officers
to the reservation, when
were a Public Law 280
state, which says, that their
state criminal jurisdiction
that rules.
So even though I'm
not a lawyer, I
had to play one on TV regularly.
[LAUGHTER]
It was called the news. [LAUGHS]
Because I had to be
able to articulate
to those other jurisdictions,
and to those other
stakeholders, why what happened
in my piece of Indian country
mattered to them, and why my
citizens continued to matter,
and that we were not
going to allow ourselves
to be ignored anymore.
But we do, and we are, and
it's very selective, right?
They look at our
economic success
and say, well, why don't
we get to have casinos.
And I would say back, well,
we are a political entities.
You're confusing our race
with our political status.
We have a different
jurisdiction.
And then, generally,
I would point
out they didn't share
250 years of oppression,
poverty, and everything
else, too, but, you know.
Politics is
personal, even to me.
But then there was
the broader picture
of talking to my citizens about
what could they expect out
of their elected leadership
that went a little bit beyond,
what can I do in
the home community?
Because I had all of
these multijuristictional
relationships to
manage, as well as,
making sure that the
2,200 employees did
service delivery, and economic
development, really well.
And I would have my home rule
community say to me, well,
why are you going to DC, Karen?
What about here?
How are you taken care of here?
And so the communication
started to begin, and we--
I ramped up my own
personal transparency,
through regular open meetings
with our own citizens,
and newspaper articles, and
tried to let them know why.
Why do I go to DC?
Why do I talk to
federal officials?
our legislators?
Why does that matter in
the home rule community?
How do we broaden the scope
of our active citizenry
to say, out there matters
as much to us, as here.
And that was the story we
really needed to get out.
Obviously, we look to
Congress to help us
with some of the poor
decisions of the Court.
Congress has plenary
power, obviously provide
a legislative fix to some of the
poor federal, and Supreme Court
decisions, [INAUDIBLE],
land into trust issues.
A very poor ruling
out of the courts
that really narrowed
the definition
of the types of lands that
the Department of Interior
can take into trusts.
We need a legislative fix.
Some of the inroads, or,
not even the inroads,
incursions into Indian
Child Welfare Act.
That's going to be
a federal response,
either through federal
agency rule-making,
or additional activity
out of Congress.
One of the things we started
with, was real basic.
You can understand
as a tribal person
why you need to be engaged
in tribal politics,
why do they need to be engaged
in the broader world politics.
And we got out the vote.
We got out the vote
in such a big way
that we swung local elections.
If you talk to Al
Franken, he will tell you,
and conf-- and say that the
Indian vote helped get him
in office.
As politics has gotten
more polarized, and-- nah,
that's not happening, right?
[LAUGHTER]
Smaller constituencies
can matter
more as we become more divided.
So the voices are even
more, and more important.
Senator Franken
won by 312 votes.
312 votes.
We registered more voters
just at Fond du Lac,
new voters that year.
We gave them rides,
we had free transit,
we did voter
registration drives,
we had, I voted, stickers,
made into our language.
And they became a thing of
pride to wear in our community
for people to vote.
We told them that your
legislators are the ones that
are your voice at
the table, and rather
than fix things that are
broken, they can be proactive.
We challenged Senator Franken
to become a member of the Senate
Committee on Indian Affairs,
because we hadn't had
one out of Minnesota, a member.
And there's 11
tribes in Minnesota.
And that we wanted him to know
that, if he wanted our support,
we expected him to be
a part of the voice.
And he did it, and
he's there, and he's
fighting for Indian
people on that committee.
As tribal governance
has grown and taken
on more responsibility,
we're starting
to see more and more
that, what you're
electing as a local
tribal leader,
isn't just somebody who
manages the governance,
you're electing an advocate.
And so we're trying
to push the idea of,
don't just vote because that
someone is your relative,
and you think that means
your family will do better
under a new regime.
But they are able to articulate
kind of the global needs
of your community.
How many children--
do we see spikes
in our local counties
of children being placed
in out-of-home placement?
What kind of economic
impact do we make?
Are they able to articulate
that a rising tide really
does lift all boats, and a
healthy tribal community,
in my case, contributed
well over $300 million
to a local role economy.
You need to have that advocacy.
Sequestration, actually,
was one of the things that
came to my people, that
was really able for them
to understand, how
does this affect me?
When we talked about, if
we're not an advocate in DC,
here's what will happen in
the home rule community,
in terms of our
service delivery.
We expect these things
to be able to not
be able to continue.
Everything from elder
Meals On Wheels,
to home health care
aides, to Head Start,
and on, and on, and on.
Now Washington,
DC, feels very real
when you're talking
about our loved ones.
The other part is, maybe not
as sexy, but just as important,
talking to our community about
the census, and participation,
and different data collection.
Data collection is
terrible in Indian country.
We are tired of people tracking
us, they track our blood,
they track where we live, they
track who our ancestors are.
Would you quit
tracking us already?
Well, here's a
tribal leader saying,
I need you to fill
out the census,
and tell some people, you
know, everything about you
that really is none of their
business, but yet it matters.
So we had our own census people,
members from our own community,
that could go in and
make our families
feel comfortable, and
understand the reason why
it was important for good data.
Because federal, and
state, and elections,
get decided based on census.
It's about redistricting,
and obviously, lately,
about gerrymandering.
That's true.
And it's about
allocations of resources.
And data collection continues
to be something that's
important in so
many ways in terms
of how states
allocate resources,
how the feds allocate resources.
Once again, DC matters to
the home rule community,
St. Paul, in Minnesota, matters
to the home rule community.
Understanding that working
with federal agencies
is also politics.
Tribes actually, because of the
Federal Trust Responsibility--
everybody know what the Federal
Trust Responsibility is?
OK.
So we prepaid for a
whole bunch of stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
We paid with the country.
And the promise was, if
we give up the country,
that some of-- that our
needs would be taken care of.
That didn't go so well, but
we're kind of expecting it now.
Our place in politics is about
saying the bill is coming due.
We would like to
be self-determined,
self-sufficient, and we would
like to carry our own water,
and be truly
self-governing, and exercise
that full political
status as sovereigns.
And then guess what?
Then you don't have to worry
about us too much anymore.
We want those
things for our self,
just like every person and
family wants it for themselves.
Working directly with
the federal government
and the agencies as politics.
At the top level you
have secretaries,
and those are
political appointees.
It matters who you elect.
I'll use the current president.
He has been the best
friend to Indian country
that we have ever seen
in the executive branch.
We are on track to take
about a 1/2 a million
more acres of tribal
homelands into trust,
as well as having a fairly
robust agenda through each
of the departments around
strengthening Indian country.
Consultation policies--
you will not do to us,
you will do with us.
We will communicate, we will
do negotiated rule-making,
and we know how best to
serve our own communities.
You have proven you're
not that good at it,
so let's have this
conversation about how to get
it done on a day-to-day basis.
We have institutionalized
the relationship, not just
the ward status.
We are a participant
in our own governance.
Finally I'll talk a little
bit about Native peoples,
and Native politics,
and saying that,
I am absolutely delighted,
as I look at social media,
and I see tribal citizens
across the country taking
that final step of
becoming candidates.
It has been something that
has been woefully lacking.
And we talked about this
in Indian country a lot
about representation.
Whether it's in our
classrooms, where our kids
can see teachers
that look like them,
and have curricula that's
reflective of them.
We talk about it in social
services, family caseworkers,
how do you know about the
dynamics in an Indian family,
if you are not
culturally competent.
And the quickest and easiest
way to get culturally competent
is to be from the culture.
This goes then to electoral
politics, as well.
If we can change
voting in Minnesota,
and elect an ally in
Al Franken, can we
turn out the vote to elect
someone who looks just
like us, from our community,
to be representative
of communities that
are largely Native.
In the Southwest
we see candidates,
we see them up in the Northwest.
We have state legislatures
who are increasingly
having people understand
that their road to higher
elected office
starts in their home
communities with local
seats, city council members,
to statewide politics, and
hopefully, quite a number more
at the federal level.
Why does that matter to people
outside of Indian country?
Our diversity is our strength.
By 2030 the majority
of this culture
will be people of color.
And that wide
fabric of diversity
is what makes us
strong, and it makes
us resilient as a country,
but only if it's inclusive.
We talk a lot at
the federal level
of how do we compete against
China, and TPP, and everything
else.
A part of it is
making sure that we
have a healthy and
participatory society, right?
Because that's where the
solutions come to homegrown
issues, and then bubble up,
and become our strength.
So, vote Indian.
[LAUGHTER]
You know you want to.
Just in closing, all
politics is personal, right?
Although you won't be seeing
me running for anything else
anytime soon.
That whole post-traumatic
stress thing.
You know, understand that
politics for Indian country
is personal.
It becomes, first and foremost,
with the home rule community.
How can we become as
healthy as we can be,
and as inclusive as we can
be in our home community.
And then making that story more
broadly to other jurisdictions,
where, hopefully, we'll
be talking to familiar
faces in the future.
And telling the story that
Native peoples-- our country
is only as healthy as
those who have the least.
So let's bring that least up,
and work towards full equality.
That's my job.
Thank you, folks.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, my name's
John Dossett, I'm
with the National Congress
of American Indians.
Thanks very much
for having me here.
I thought before I
started-- my presentation,
I was really going to leap
right into sort of recent events
in working with Congress,
and the administration,
getting a lot of policy
things done, but I thought,
maybe, first, I should tell you
a little bit about the National
Congress of American Indians.
NCAI is a membership
organization of Indian tribes
from around the United States.
There's about 250 member
tribes, that varies
a little bit from year to year.
The tribes get together
about three times a year,
and they pass
resolutions, and then
those resolutions are--
they're the marching orders
for the staff of NCAI,
what we're supposed
to try to achieve with
Congress, and what
we try to achieve collectively.
The mission statement,
or the preamble
to the NCAI constitution
says that our goal
is to advance
tribal sovereignty,
and respect for tribal laws,
treaty rights, and the Federal
Trust Responsibility.
To promote the common
welfare of Indian people,
and educate the public towards
a better understanding.
So that's the broad
goals of NCAI.
And NCAI, over the
years, formed in 1944,
fought against
termination, then pushed
the self-determination policy.
And since then NCAI
has probably been
involved in most of the major
laws and regulations that
have-- working to
advance Indian policy.
So with that, I guess I'll
turn to my next subject.
And I guess it was,
you know, when I first
talked about this with
Maggie McKinley, Maggie--
she wanted me to talk about
Indian tribal leaders,
and NCAI, and how we
work on lobbying issues,
and that we need to reclaim
the language of lobbying.
And I thought-- it was a
little bit dissonant for me
because, I don't think
tribal leaders have ever
thought of lobbying as
anything but 100% good.
Lobbying, it isn't some--
it isn't a thing where
there's-- it's not shady
or corrupt, I mean,
maybe that's something in
other parts of America that--
but, I think tribal leaders
really see this as, you know,
the right to petition for
the redress of grievances.
They're in the mode
of advancing what--
trying to make good things
happen for their cultures,
and for their tribes back home.
And I've never had
any sense that it's
anything less than what
we ought to be doing.
In fact, tribal
leaders consider it
sort of a privilege, and
an honor, and a duty,
to lobby on behalf
of their tribes.
And it's not something that
they'd ever consider anything
less than what everybody ought
to want to do with their life.
So I've been very lucky
to work with this group,
and I enjoy it a great deal.
I thought I'd start by,
maybe bragging a little bit
about tribal leaders, and about
what this administration has
accomplished.
And so here's a
series of photographs.
This here is the Tribal
Law and Order Act.
And I always like to point
out in these photographs,
I mean, it isn't just
one guy, President Obama
didn't do this all by himself.
There's members of Congress,
there's tribal leaders,
and all working together
to pass this legislation.
This is the HEARTH
Act, this is the-- we
talked about the Tribal
Law and Order Act
before, the HEARTH Act was
the one where tribes can now
control leasing on their
own lands, at least surface
leasing, which is a
great step forward.
And this was the Violence
Against Women Act
Reauthorization, and this
was a huge crowd of people.
And I will-- and, as you see
in this photo, a lot of folks
here, the Violence
Against Women Act
was a coalition much broader
than Indian country itself.
The National Task Force
to End Domestic Violence,
and all kinds of folks
are involved in that.
So I want to-- in
addition to that,
some of the other recent
things that this administration
and tribal leaders have achieved
working together, amendments
to the Stafford Acts
so that tribes can now
request their own disaster
declarations in Indian country.
They don't have to
work through the state.
There are now new
guidelines and regulations
pending on the Indian
Child Welfare Act.
Tribes have achieved land
into trust over 400,000 acres,
I think that's 625 square
miles of land into trust,
massively improved processes,
much quicker land into trust
processes, land into
trust in Alaska, which
is going to be a
great step forward,
and then a lot of
reservation proclamations.
There'd been quite a number of
settlements in Indian country,
the Cobell settlement for
mismanagement of Indian trust
funds, 86 tribal cases
over $2.8 billion.
The Contract Support Litigation
for self-determination,
and self-governance
contracts, about $1.5 billion
there, about $2 billion worth
of water rights settlements,
the Keepseagle settlement
for discrimination
against Native American
farmers, altogether, this
might be about $10 billion in
settlements for Indian country
that tribes have
worked with Congress,
and the administration, to
achieve over the last seven
years.
So I started-- I
wanted to keep a list,
because so many good
things were happening
during these last
years, that I was like,
somebody better write this
down, or else nobody's going
to remember this stuff, right?
It all goes by in
kind of a blur.
So I started keeping
a list, and you know,
I used to keep it on this one
slide of all these great things
that had happened.
But now I have to go
into a second slide,
and then keep talking
about all the good things--
these ICWA regulations
the retrocessions,
the new right of way
regulations, where tribes can
preempt state taxes on
Indian reservations,
and collect their own taxes.
And then I had to keep going
with a third slide of things
that have continued to
happen in Indian country.
I think in some
ways it's possible
that tribal governments
have achieved
more, working with
this administration,
than any other group.
It's really amazing
all that's been done.
And we're trying to keep
track of everything,
but if I lost track
of some stuff.
But, anyway, thanks to tribal
leaders, like Karen Diver,
and administration officials,
like Karen Diver, it's really--
[LAUGHTER]
gotten a lot done.
So I want to talk a
little bit about how
we can keep this going.
You know, tribal
leaders are out there,
and Karen talked about
this, working together,
and by themselves,
to educate Congress
and the administration.
Getting out the vote, and
getting bipartisan support.
Having that leadership
from the administration
and the leadership in Congress.
And it's really important to
have bipartisan leadership.
And then coalition
building in Indian country.
And that's really what
I'm going to focus on,
it's coalition building.
And here's a couple other
points, but keep it going.
So I wanted to focus on one
coalition building effort that
was a really important one,
that we were very honored
to work on.
And I wanted to show this
photograph because I think
it emphasizes the coalition.
You know, there's a
tendency, I think sometimes,
as if, you know, there were one,
or two, charismatic people who
got a lot of stuff
done, and it's,
I think, maybe afterwards,
we impose that narrative
on what happened.
But really when
it's going on it's
a swarm of people all over the
country doing amazing things.
And here's just an example
of part of that swarm.
And there are many
different points in time
when individuals
step up to the plate,
and they keep pushing the ball
forward in critical events,
and it takes this whole
series of serendipitous events
to get you to the point.
And this expansion of tribal
jurisdiction over non-Indians
of the Violence
Against Women Act,
was really one of those things,
where a lot of different things
came together, a lot of
people came together.
It was really great
to be a part of it,
and that's what I
wanted to talk about,
is that kind of
coalition building.
As background on this
issue, I think it-- maybe
it started with the Tribal
Law and Order Act discussions,
when, in 2007, they
started holding hearings.
And this problem of
domestic violence
committed by non-Indians really
began coming to the forefront.
There were a lot of
hearings held in Congress
during that time.
And these facts kept coming
forward, 61% of Native women
have been subject
to assault, that's
triple the national rate.
66% of the perpetrators
are non-Indian.
There's this in-- the
federal government
is the only entity that has
jurisdiction over non-Indians,
until recently, anyway.
And there's this
incredibly high rate
of declinations, where the
federal government won't
prosecute these cases,
particularly domestic violence
cases, because they're
kind of hard to prosecute.
And that tribal governments
are the only entity
that could provide
safety for Native women.
So this proposed
remedy came forward
to amend the Indian Civil
Rights Act to restore
tribal jurisdiction
over non-Indians
for domestic violence crimes.
There were a whole bunch of
factors that fed into this,
and I think, first
of all, we have
to credit the VAWA movement more
generally across the country.
I mean, they passed the Violence
Against Women Act in 1994,
I think before tribes
were deeply involved.
But the infrastructure
that they set up,
particularly the shelters,
and then funding the shelters
on Indian reservations,
funding the victims
advocates around the country.
That infrastructure,
I think, created
the basis for what then
went forward from there.
And some of that took
place in the NCAI Violence
Against Women Task Force,
led by tribal leaders,
like Juana Majel,
and Terri Henry,
where they've been pushing
this issue probably
since about 1999.
So it really-- I guess one
point I want to get across
is these kind of things, you may
think it all happened in 2013,
they started working on that
like a decade and a half
to get to that point.
There were some very important
studies, the Ninth Circuit
Gender Bias Task Force
report that came out in 1997,
highlighted this problem,
and it was this really great,
you know, the Ninth Circuit
judges come out with a report,
highlighting the issue,
from a long time ago.
The fact that there was
now crime data-- crime
data in Indian country
wasn't generally available
until the Clinton administration
started collecting it.
So that-- you know that data
that I just recited to you,
that's pretty compelling?
None of that existed
until before then.
We had an NCAI
resolution as of 2003,
the Lara case came along,
that Maze of Injustice report
was incredibly important,
from Amnesty International.
Anyway, there was
this whole series
of events that led to this.
I probably think the most
important thing was native vote
overall.
When it came right
down to it, when
we were trying to get the
bill through the house,
you know, it was a Republican
House of Representatives,
they weren't
generally supportive,
but it was about finding
enough Republicans
to go with the
Democrats, who were
going to vote for the bill.
So we got out the map, and
there are 63 Republicans who
have Indian tribes
in their districts,
and we started targeting them,
one after another, and flipping
them over to the other side.
And then by the time we got
to about 60, it was like,
OK, the bill headed to the
floor, and it went to a vote.
So the fact that tribes
are turning out the vote,
even if it's small
tribes in one district,
it's just incredibly
important for politics.
And in the end, that's
what got the bill done,
and it showed itself
in this legislation.
This was a slide
that one of the-- I
think the National Indian
Women's Resource Center,
they had a
presentation about it--
and this was as it was going on.
And I just thought it was a nice
graphic of how the coalition
building process works.
I mean, it really isn't
one person, or one entity,
it's everybody working together.
This is a photograph of a group
of women in North Dakota--
South Dakota, who
are-- they were
holding marches and rallies.
I mean, this was going on all
across the country in 2012,
and 2013.
And it was like we're-- it
was like a social movement,
you know, like people
heard about it.
It was the most exciting
thing I've been involved in.
I wanted to-- Sarah Deer-- there
are probably some academics
here in the crowd,
so there is a role
for academics in this process.
And Sarah Deer and her Maze of
Injustice Report, I thought,
were very important in
moving this forward.
But it wasn't those-- it wasn't
this report all by itself.
This was just one more piece
of the puzzle coming together
so everybody can play a role.
And you just have to watch
these issues and figure out
the right timing, and
when to come forward.
So this new law,
what it did is, it
affirmed tribal
inherent authority
to exercise criminal
jurisdiction
over domestic violence,
dating violence,
and violation of
protection orders.
Those violations of
protective orders
aren't just intimate partners,
that could be anybody.
So that's really, I
mean, in some ways
people think that this is
fairly narrow jurisdiction,
but when you think
about this authority
to criminally prosecute any
violation of protection order,
you could get jurisdiction
over just about anyone,
by first issuing a protection
order, and then enforcing it.
There are 12 tribes who
are currently implementing,
I think there are
more on the way.
There have been more than
50 cases prosecuted to date.
So far the experience
shows that there
have been some difficulties with
child victims, related crimes,
like if you find a drug
crime at the same scene,
and then, how violent
does it have to be?
Exactly, what is violence?
So there is already
legislation pending in Congress
to address these issues
that got introduced
a month, or two, ago.
So I think that can show you
how this stuff, this ball,
is continuing to roll.
You know, now we have
data about what's
going on in these--
at the 12 tribes
who are already prosecuting, and
it continues to move forward,
and we're going
to keep it going.
I'll skip past this one.
If you want to learn more about
the VAWA issue, here it is.
One of the tricks
of lobbying is,
when you're sitting in
front of a decision maker,
like Karen Diver,
for instance, you
might want to talk about
issues that are important you.
So I was going to highlight
a couple of other issues--
[LAUGHTER]
--that are coming up.
And this is more
coalition work that we all
need to work together on.
And there are some things
that we really want to submit.
The administration has achieved
this amazing list of things,
but there's a couple more
things we'd like to get done.
One of them is to modernize
the Indian Trader Regulations.
The secretary has authority
to regulate, basically,
trade with the Indians
on reservations.
And the administration's
been really
great about asserting that in
the [INAUDIBLE] litigation,
where the state is
collecting dual taxation
on the reservation.
And at least in my
opinion, this is
the-- why are Indian
reservations always struggling
economically?
It's because the
states tax everything,
and then they don't
provide any services,
and then the tribes
can't tax on top of that.
If tribes-- if you can
eliminate the state taxes,
and tribe could collect
their own taxes,
tribes could provide
taxes-- you know,
services on the
reservation, just
like most other
local communities do.
But they've been unable to
do that because of a series
of bad Supreme Court decisions.
But there is this
proposal, pending
at the Department of
Interior, that we'd really
like them to move
forward on, that
would empower tribal
business licensing,
there would be consent to
tribal jurisdiction addressing
the Dollar General case, and
would eliminate dual taxation.
Another interesting one
that's going on right
now is this Bears Ears
National Monument.
This is also a coalition of five
tribes out of the Southwest.
They are asking the
federal government
to create a national
monument through presidential
proclamation to set aside
1.9 million acres of very
important tribal
cultural sacred lands,
but to do it under
tribal code management,
under a code management
plan, it would really
be an amazing step forward.
Charles Wilkinson is
working with the tribes
in that area on
this, so it's really
a very interesting development.
So the last thing
I wanted to share
with you is, this is the--
staff come in to NCAI,
and they're like,
OK, what do we do?
So this is the formula that--
I think we have at NCAI-- this
is what you do with your job.
You study the issue, you've
got to know it really well,
and you identify a solution.
This is a lot more
work than you think,
but this is basically
the part of it.
Second, you've got to
identify the decision
makers, and the process that
you're going to go through.
Whether you're
working with Congress,
which there's-- and there's
a process and rules for all
of this stuff.
Also, working with the
agencies, so understanding
those rules, and the
process, and how it works,
it's not that much
different than being
a lawyer in the courts.
There's rules and a process.
You've got to have very
concise, short messages,
and make sure that
they're delivered.
Know the timing, you get
them-- you got to deliver them,
you do it early,
you do a follow up,
and then right at the decision
time, you do it again.
You share all this information
with your coalition,
and you ask them to do
the same things that
they're-- everybody's
on the same page,
putting all these messages in
front of the decision makers.
And then you work with
media, and social media,
to make sure that the message
spreads as far as you can.
Anyway, there you go.
That's the advocacy formula
that we use at NCAI.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
-[INAUDIBLE].
If you see me like, sitting over
there, and have my head down,
I'm tweeting.
[LAUGHTER]
It's not that I'm
not paying attention,
I'm tweeting out to people.
I want to thank Harvard
and I want to thank
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] I
want to thank the creator,
the four directions,
and our Mother Earth,
for being here today.
And I want to thank
the Original Peoples
for the lands in
which we are in today,
and I want to thank them
for inviting me in here.
I also want to thank
the organizers,
incredible organizing,
well done, very smooth.
Thank you for that.
Today I'm going to talk about
something very different,
and I'm going to try
and talk about it.
I'm going to be teaching it
for a week in Jasper, Alberta.
I am from the Treaty 6 lands of
the [INAUDIBLE], I am nêhiyaw.
In English we are
called the Cree people.
Now, what I'm going
to talk to you,
I have to talk to you in
15 minutes, and less--
[LAUGHTER]
--in a four-day
intensive program.
[LAUGHS] So, if I sound like
an auctioneer, I apologize.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to have to
move very quickly.
How many of you have heard
of the Doctrine of Discovery?
Wonderful, wonderful.
I want to also ask, are there
indigenous people in the crowd?
Wonderful.
I wanted to tell you, you
are our ancestors prayers
made flesh.
I'm so grateful that
you're here today amidst
all of the brutal genocide
that we've lived through
to stand here today.
So, at the time-- this
is really important,
so you have to follow
me very quickly.
I have to teach you
quickly on this.
And I know that
the USA and Canada
have very parallel histories,
because I researched it.
And I'm not saying I'm an
expert in the US law, I'm not.
I am a lawyer in the
Canadian common law system,
and I'm primarily a researcher.
So the Doctrine of Discovery
is under the umbrella
of the Manifest Destiny
[INAUDIBLE] indigenous peoples.
The original peoples were
considered the flora and fauna,
we're not human.
We are not human.
I say that over, and over
again, because that's
what rolls out in every policy
and law that we see today.
Today.
And I want the young
people to know,
and I want the
indigenous women to know,
that this system targets you
as the most marginalized,
and the most hated.
And I am very blunt because I
don't have time for niceties.
Christian monarchs at that
time worked with Pope Alexander
in creating, from the
imaginations of men,
from the imaginations of a
pope, a Doctrine of Discovery.
And it's exactly the
same here for you,
except you had Columbus.
We had John Cabot, The Explorer.
So John Cabot came across
the ocean with instruments,
and when he arrived,
and these instruments
were the charters directed from
the pope-- OK, from the pope.
And when he arrived here
he did a Christian chant.
The very first thing he did when
he landed on Original People's
soil, he got off his
boat, went to our lands,
took instruments that he
carried across the ocean,
and did a very-- the very
first act that he did
was a Christian chant, and
he put that instrument deep
in the soil of our
people's lands,
and he baptized our lands for
the sovereign, for the pope.
That's a very symbolic
Christian and sovereign act
of those nations
across the ocean,
and very important for us today.
At that moment, when he did
that, the presumed sovereignty
of the monarch, the presumed
sovereignty on our side
was the British rule.
It was crystallized, as
they say in law, right?
Crystallized at that moment.
This is the timeline.
So before that, the
Original Peoples
lived in independent, powerful
societies governed by our laws,
the original instructions
given to us by our [INAUDIBLE],
or for other
nations, however you
choose to call your
spiritual entities.
With my people we call
him [NON-ENGLISH],
our original instructions,
vibrant, beautiful.
And when the Doctrine
of Christian Discovery
was applied in 1497,
the crystallization
of their presumed sovereignty
rolled out onto our lands,
without our knowledge,
without our consent.
And then a series of events
happened from that moment on,
the Royal Proclamation,
in the 1700s, consolidated
with the Doctrine of
Discovery, consolidated
Discovery, and they took us
under their wing because
we were not human.
We became wards of this colonial
state, and we are not human.
And at that moment, when we
were taken under their wing,
we see a lot of colonial
policies and laws
coming out of there.
We hear the language, fiduciary,
trust-like, coming out
of there.
And it's because
we're not human.
I keep repeating
that because that's
what comes out of these
court cases, the Indian Act,
and everything that
we're hearing today.
Then something else happened,
Johnson versus M'Intosh,
in 1923, came out
of here, and then
Canada took it, and
applied it over there.
And then became a
series of case law
that said we were
parasitic on the underlying
title of the crown.
The underlying
title of the crown
is the Doctrine of Discovery.
You need to understand that.
The Doctrine of Discovery,
in this case law,
has been disguised at the
underlying title of the crown.
It's a myth, and a lie
told over, and over again,
every time we go to court.
Every time we go to court
they apply the underlying
title of the crown, which
is a myth, and a lie,
from the imaginations of
men who brought it here.
From there, in Canada, they
created the British North
America Act, and
they took our lands,
instantly condemning
us into poverty,
instantly making them wealthy.
Because in [? 9124 ?] they
took our lands, lands,
and Indian lands
reserved for Indians,
instantly condemning
us into poverty.
A direct connection to
the Doctrine of Discovery,
because as human
beings, as non-humans,
as non-human beings,
we cannot own property.
We had no laws, we were
barbarians, savages.
And then from there they
created the Indian Act,
and then from there
the number of treaties.
Think about that.
The treaties were
created on the notion
that our lands have
already been taken.
All of our resources
have already
been taken by the
Doctrine of Discovery,
by the underlying
title of the crown.
And then from there,
today, even in the US,
I see that language,
the language
that they used in calling
us stakeholders, occupiers.
And then we see the
land claims process
that we have to go to their
artificial illegal system
to gain back our lands.
How ridiculous is that?
How awful is that?
And then we see the
Treaty Land Entitlement,
Indian residential schools.
You know what the Indian
residential schools did?
And I'm sure they did
the very same thing here.
We have something in
a number of treaties,
and I'm from Treaty 6,
and I've researched this.
I even wrote a book called,
Nationhood Interrupted,
Revitalizing Nehiyaw
Legal Systems,
and I talk about
this in chapter 4.
And I talk about a treaty
term and promise, where, and
I'm quoting from the treaty
negotiations, where it says,
for a family of-- one square
mile, for a family of five,
more or less.
I have seven children,
eight, including myself.
I'm supposed to be entitled,
by that treaty term
and promise, a one square mile.
I have yet to see that.
It's my dream in my lifetime
that the treaty term
and promise will be fulfilled.
But what happened
at the time when
Indian residential schools,
when they came for the children?
How was the fastest way
to prevent a treaty term
and promise from
being fulfilled?
Was the fastest way?
Anyone guess?
You take the children.
You can no longer meet the
criteria of a family, right.
You take the children.
In total violation
of what we thought
was an authentic treaty.
And then you see
the conversations
about self-government.
And during this era
we see the Indian Act.
And right away, the first
language you see is,
an Indian woman cannot vote.
And Indian woman
will lose her status
if she marries a non-Indian man.
The target of women was
insidious, insidious.
In 1670 the Jesuits came
looking for my people,
indigenous nehiyaw people.
And they found them
in the James Bay Area.
And if you see the
journals of the Jesuits,
right away they
say, the Cree women
have far too much
authority and jurisdiction.
We have to eliminate that.
It took them a long time,
but they became successful.
Today our matrilineal
societies are so decimated,
they're a mere shadow
of what they should be.
What they should be,
they're a shadow of it.
Another thing happened,
as they were working
to dismantle and abolish the
authority of indigenous women,
the Original Peoples'
jurisdiction,
they began to target the women.
In the Indian Act they targeted
the birthright to determine who
their citizens are by
legislating who they can marry
and who they cannot.
And another thing-- I'm
not for voting, by the way,
and I'll tell you why
in two minutes or less.
[LAUGHTER]
So, women, under the Indian
Act, were not allowed to vote,
nor were they allowed
to run for leadership.
And when that ended
about, between 1940--
and there's debate
in that-- into 1960,
another thing happened, they
rolled out the traplines,
from 1945, to what we see today.
And the traplines are
anywhere, from 95% to 98%,
under the men's names.
The women in my nation have
jurisdiction and authority
over land and water, because
we carry the water ceremonies.
We carry them.
That has been decimated under
this Doctrine of Discovery.
All of us need to
understand, we have
to work collectively and be
very strong in abolishing
the Doctrine of Discovery.
And what will that mean?
I don't know.
I'm not sure because
I'm still researching.
This is relatively new to me.
I was blown away when I
was going to law school.
Why weren't we not told that
the underlying title was
the Doctrine of Discovery?
When we go, and I say this
with all respect, and kindness,
and I know it's-- I'm not
here to offend anyone,
nor to demean your work--
but when we go to vote
in their systems, or to
run in their systems,
we entrench them, and
we legitimize them,
when we should be
stepping away, and saying,
you do not have authority to
be putting this system out that
dehumanizes women, that
marginalizes women,
continues the patriarchy
and the misogyny,
especially on indigenous women.
We have missing
or murdered women
in Canada, the official
numbers, approximately 1,300.
The unofficial number
is approximately 4,000.
In my own family, my brother
was murdered, two of my aunties
were murdered.
And that's not a unique story.
Every indigenous family that you
talk to, this is their story.
We have to change that story.
We need to believe and
envision a time of freedom
for indigenous people,
because we do not have it.
We do not have it.
Not as long as the
Doctrine of Discovery
still applies as the
underlying title, giving
jurisdiction to the colonizer
in an illegal imagining,
coming from it.
I want a dream, I have a dream,
that some day, in my lifetime,
I will see my grandchildren
born in freedom and liberation,
and self-determination.
That's my dream.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I speak my language
today because something
happened that's very unique.
My great grandmother didn't
go to residential school.
When the Indian agent and the
priest came for the children,
they were hidden away deep
in the forests of my people.
My grandmother, same thing,
my mother same thing--
hidden away.
With me, same
thing, hidden away.
I'm grateful for that today.
Speak my language.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you so much, Sylvia.
That was remarkable.
So we're going to go straight
to audience question and answer.
Once again, we have
a mic set up there.
Please form a line behind the
microphone, and approach--
-Remember, lunch is next.
-Yes, remember lunch
is next, and remember
that there are other people
who wish to ask questions.
So I would ask you all to
keep your questions brief,
in respect of others, and of our
assembled audience and panel.
Thank you.
-I'm Todd Larson, I've
had a long term interest
in Native American issues.
And I recall a 1980s documentary
film called, Broken Rainbow,
which documented the
continuous displacement
of Native American reservations
to other parts of Arizona,
so that those former
reservations could be exploited
by private companies.
And I remember one
scene, where one
of the Native American leaders
petitioned senators like,
Daniel Inouye and
Barry Goldwater,
to stop this relocation,
concluding with the statement,
Congress, wake up.
And the senators refused
to do anything about it.
So I'm wondering if any of you
know if this trend in Arizona
is still continuing?
Or if any laws have improved
to try to reduce, or eliminate,
this problem?
-Sure, I mean, at least-- what I
think you may be talking about,
and I'll let other
folks get to this,
is that there was quite
a dispute in the 1980s
over the Navajo Hopi relocation,
and got on the television
quite a bit then.
I don't really know
the-- and I'm not
going to weigh in on how
that issue is resolved.
I think there's still
probably some tensions there.
-Subsurface rights?
Yeah, there are still issues.
For surface rights,
the HEARTH Act actually
has-- so, some of it depends
on the treaty language
of the individual tribes.
But the HEARTH Act removes
the Department of Interior
and the Bureau of Indian Affairs
from managing leasehold rights
within Indian country.
So, yes, there's a
partial fix, and there
are some still outstanding.
-Thank you.
-Hi, my name is
Tanya [INAUDIBLE],
I was born as an
Armenian in Turkey.
And Armenian people were
also subjected to genocide,
except we couldn't talk
about it in Turkey.
I am here now with a gratitude
to the Native Peoples,
obviously, and also fortunate
to have gone to Harvard.
I have two questions, one is,
how do you feel about the fact
that it has not been
officially acknowledged
that Native American people
were subjected to genocide?
And the second one,
my second question
is about domestic
violence issues,
how do you feel about
whether those who perpetrate
domestic violence, if they
are Indians themselves,
should they be judged
only in Indian courts,
or should there be
appeals, should they also
be subject to US persecution?
Thank you.
-[INAUDIBLE].
-Regarding the domestic
violence issue,
there is quite a
bit of attention
right now in Indian
country around
building more robust
tribal court system,
including wellness courts.
So, when you look at a
lot of crime, regardless
of the race of the
perpetrator, sometimes
that's a symptom
of something else,
whether it's mental health
issues, chemical dependency.
So what you want to do is get
at the root of the issues.
And then there's also
around reconciliation
in the community,
restorative justice
issues, and more traditional
ways of handling crime.
So an awfully big
push right now, quite
a number of federal agencies,
a whole robust system
of doing an assessment
process in the community.
Of not only, what do
they need to do to build
their tribal court system?
But a set of holistic services
around the court system
so you can work on actually
getting better, rather than
just throwing them in jail, and
throwing away our men, women,
or perpetrators.
Now I'll let him
take the other issue.
No?
-I don't-- I don't have anything
-Sylvia, did you want to
talk to the woman's question
about acknowledgement
of genocide, or no?
You don't have to.
-I think at this point, until
we revitalize our own systems
of justice, as in limitation
to the English language,
I think utilizing both systems
is acceptable because sometimes
I notice that decisions are not
exactly healthy when they come
out of our own systems because
of the effects of colonization,
right?
Those are the effects of that
patriarchy and the misogyny,
and the hatred against women.
And one of the examples
to that, that I talk about
is, I recently ran for Indian
Act chief in my system,
to try and disrupt some of
those narratives, right?
We've never had a woman for
chief, or a woman in council.
And while I was running I
was told, in the language,
I was told [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
It means, women don't
belong in leadership.
You go home and
make [? bannock. ?]
And I'm one of higher
educated people there.
But that gives you an idea
of some of the dynamics
that we have to deal
with in the community,
and that's the effects
of colonization.
So both systems,
I would support.
Both systems.
-I think we're going to move
on to the next question.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
-It'd be nice to
hear you're sorry.
-I'm Tunica-Biloxi, and
Mississippi Choctaw,
enrolled in the Tunica-Biloxi
Tribe of Louisiana.
My name is Jean-Luc
[INAUDIBLE] To our membership,
our governments operate
under the assumption
that to get forward
legislatively we
have to ante up
hundreds of thousands
of dollars in
lobbying expenditures.
What can we do to organize our
communities, our Indian people,
to combat moneyed interests
and lobbyists that
may influence our councils?
Because with IRA constitutions
and unilateral governments
our sovereignty is abused
more often than not.
-I know that some
tribes have adopted
ethical rules, internal ethical
rules, about the kinds of gifts
that tribal council members
can receive in order
to address that issue.
It's becoming, I think,
more and more common.
It used to be that there
weren't a lot of resources
around the tribes, I mean, there
wasn't a great deal of interest
in influencing tribal council.
But now that there's more
money involved, there is.
So tribes, these days,
they're in a position
where they need to think
about internal ethical rules.
-And mineral rights,
as well, are at stake.
-Can I follow up on that just
for the panel really quickly?
In the past 40, or 50
years, some tribes-- and I'm
speaking mainly of what
I know about the US,
and less about
First Nations-- have
become wealthier, have
become more powerful,
and others much less.
And so there's been
this divergence.
And what does that fact of
wealthier tribes and less
wealthy tribes, and potentially
that divergence in wealth
and power, mean for the kind
of coalitions that you build,
that you've built others?
and, does it create
more tensions,
does it create opportunities?
How do you deal with this
kind of changing landscape
of wealthier, more powerful,
and less powerful, less wealthy,
tribal governments?
-How has the United States
dealt with less wealthy states--
-Yes, well--
---that are next door
to wealthier states?
-Yeah, that's-- I
don't know, so--
-Do I have to say more?
-OK.
[LAUGHTER]
-You need not.
-OK.
-Next question.
[LAUGHTER]
-My name's Nancy Krieger, I'm
a professor at the Harvard TH
Chan School of Public Health.
I'm here very much
today to learn,
and very appreciative of
this day and the panel.
And my question
to you is, health
becomes a way of uniting
many different sectors
in government, many
different coalitions,
in and outside of government,
and provides a lens for change
that's for good.
And I'm just wondering
if each of you
could reflect on ways that you
think people in public health
can be working more
effectively, efficaciously,
cross collaboratively,
cross-sectorly,
where health fits
in, right to health,
to advance the kinds of concerns
that you were talking about.
Because I think that there's
a particular responsibility
and obligation, within
the [INAUDIBLE] to do so.
And I also think there's a
lot to learn and benefit from.
So I just be really
curious, just as-- this
is an open-ended
question with no agenda,
other than to learn, and
to hear your thoughts,
and your challenges.
-I'll give one answer.
I think one of the
great advances,
recently, was the passage of the
Indian Health Care Improvement
Act, as a part of the
Affordable Care Act.
And tribes now have the ability
to define their own service
populations, and provide
services to anyone,
and then to do
third-party billing,
whether it's to
Medicare, or Medicaid,
or the VA, or private insurance.
And some tribes are becoming
regional health care providers.
I know of tribes out
in the Northwest,
you know, they've got
26 doctors on staff,
they're setting up facilities.
At least, I think
that, that may be
one of the great
opportunities coming,
is for tribes to really expand
providing health care, not
just to their own community,
but to everybody around them.
And then through that
being able to increase
the amount of services they can
provide to their own members,
as well.
-So we continue to
face a public health
crisis in Indian country.
The average age of
death in the 70s,
for a Native American
person, was around 56.
Now that number, I
believe, is in the low 70s,
still well below the
national average.
A lot of chronic
conditions, particularly
hit hard by diabetes,
which many attribute
to the quick change in diet
in the reservation system.
Additionally, the
reservations themselves,
and how isolated they are,
and coupled with poverty,
and things like that--
even though I was teasing
him-- create food
deserts, and things
like that, which they catch
up with you later, obviously,
in terms of chronic conditions.
Indian Health Service continues
to be funded at only about 48%
of defined need.
Before the Obama administration
it was in the 30s, 30%,
so even though we've done
well, and getting it better,
it's still not adequate.
Attracting and retaining quality
staff in the Indian country
remains a hardship,
because there's
a lack of workforce,
housing-- so these are just
like huge complex issues.
On the other hand,
you've seen tribes
under self-governance,
who have made
huge inroads in terms
of public health,
and really restructuring
how they deliver
care, one, around cultural
competency, but also,
really a holistic approach.
You can go in and
get your ear checked,
and they're going to check
your toes if you're diabetic.
And even if you're
not diabetic, so
that we're no longer
managing the outcomes,
we're managing health.
There's-- and getting back
to traditional food sources,
you know, there's this big
cycle of what goes around comes
around, and this ties
back to our, one,
right to health care as part
of the Trust Responsibility,
and a treaty right, but also
the ties that we have around
managing natural resources,
and our rights to hunt, fish,
and gather.
And get our people back
to those traditional food
sources, where it leads
to better health outcomes.
But the quality of
that resource matters.
We can't tell our
people to eat fish,
if our fish have
too much mercury.
We can't harvest wild
rice if the water
is of such poor
condition that it
reduces the quality
of the harvest,
and on, and on, and on.
So, it's not as
simple as saying,
more doctors, more
health education,
it is about being better.
Being better to our planet,
being better to our community,
making sure that they have
access, and the economics,
to have a well-rounded
diet, and to be
able to afford-- I bought an
apple the other day, it was $1.
A whole dollar, you
know what I mean?
And so, when we
tell our families,
you need to have access
to fruits and vegetables,
you need access to an
economy to make that happen,
and too many of our
reservation communities
still don't have as robust
access to a living wage.
-The other thing I
would suggest is,
being an ally to the
indigenous peoples,
or the Original
Peoples close by here,
and ask them, and approach
them, what is it that you need?
What can we do to support you?
They absolutely
have the answers.
In my own community, after
I didn't get in for chief,
I went-- I'm not
a political person
by any stretch of
the imagination.
I'm not an activist or
an environmentalist,
I am a defender and
protector of my homelands.
When I was going door to
door, and I found this man
in just a inhumane situation.
He had been homeless
for 15 years,
he dug a hole in the ground,
and basically put some boards
together.
And yet, our reserve
built a $450,000 church
almost literally
right beside him.
See, there's these-- just
a conflict in ideology.
Anyway, I told him, even if
I don't get in for chief,
I was going to see
what I could do.
I don't want to leave you the
impression that I work alone,
I don't.
I just have an idea and
some brilliant people
bring it to life.
I work with really incredibly,
incredibly powerful corps
of people.
And we decided that
we would fund-raise.
So we fund-raised for him,
and we raised about $25,000.
And today he has a mini
home that's self-sustaining,
and it's built from material
that is eco-friendly.
So now he has a home,
but it's healthy.
But you should see him
today, he's about 45,
but he looks much
older than that.
Because that's what stress
and injustice does to people,
it ages them.
But today he has a home,
and it's off the grid.
All of us will go without
power, but he won't even notice.
[LAUGHTER]
He has a wood stove that
can generate electricity,
-Cool.
-Right?
That's the law of our people.
You live it, you don't just
talk about it, you live it.
If you see injustice you try
to do something about it.
And I do little actions to try
and live our self-determination
already.
But reach out to the indigenous
people, to the Original
Peoples, and ask
them, what can we
do to support you in abolishing
the Doctrine of Discovery?
So that there's a way
to begin the dialogue,
to get your lands back, so
that you get your health back.
Because shelter, health, land,
is everything, everything.
-Unfortunately-- can you make
your question very, very brief?
I'll make it as brief as I
possibly can, is that OK?
-Yeah.
-I'm Jamie Bissonnette Lewey.
I'm Abenaki, from
Odanak First Nation,
but I'm also the chair of
the Maine Indian Tribal State
Commission.
And as-- many of the
Northeast tribes,
here, are subject to restrictive
settlement acts, which are more
onerous than Public Law 280.
I'm wondering, Sylvia,
if you could comment
on the impact that acknowledged
treaty reservations might have
on these laws, and the
protections, and preservation,
of existence and
natural resources?
Because in the laws--
is the treaties.
And then, perhaps,
attorney Dossett,
how the settlement
acts impact both VAWA,
and Collins Colloquy
on the Stafford Act?
Thank you.
-I would suggest--
and this is what's
happening in my
homelands over there,
and that's what
started, Idle No More.
It was us talking about
our inherent structures,
and our laws.
Now, the Canadian
government is inviting us
to the table saying, hey,
let's talk about your laws,
how can we apply them?
But we have to be
careful in how it--
is it going to be immersed
into that colonial, artificial,
structure of governance, right?
Is it going to get
assimilated in there,
or is it going to be
a separate entity?
And this is going to be a
dialogue for all indigenous,
or Original Peoples.
And I suggest to you
to begin revisiting,
what are your laws to the water?
What are your laws to the land?
What is your constitution
that must begin incorporating
all of these laws?
And I talk about
that in my book.
And if you could get
a hold of my book,
and it's available through my
publisher, Purich Publishing.
And you could use
it as a template.
I'm not saying is the
answer to everything,
but at least it
will guide a seed
into beginning to
talk about your laws.
Because we're not a lawless
people, we are not lawless.
We have beautiful laws.
And they weren't perfect,
but they're beautiful,
and they did work.
And those are the kind of
things that your community needs
to talk about.
We need to start
acting like nations.
-On the Stafford Act--
just very quickly--
I think that what you mention
is a very good example
of the problem with the
Maine Settlement Act.
That when the Stafford
Act came through,
there actually was this debate
with the Maine legislators,
like, should the
Maine tribes really be
able to-- if there's a
flood, or a storm, you know,
should they be able to get a
disaster declaration so they
could get emergency relief?
And people in the state were
like questioning whether that's
a good idea, like, you know,
the state should really
have jurisdiction over them.
I think the colloquy
was intended
to help the tribes in
Maine get over that.
But I think it's just an
example of what a problem
the Maine Settlement Act
is, and it's something
we need to keep working on.
-Thank you.
Karen Diver, John
Dossett, Sylvia McAdam,
thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]